e
well good morning everybody I think
we're ready to go ahead uh I'd like to
welcome our substitutes to the committee
Let's see we have representative uh Leon
here representative fellow here
uh represent svin yes anybody on this
side yeah repres Heath you're you're
usually over here on this side I
change Mary Mary Beth used to be right
there so um okay we we have some bills
which we're we're up for executing today
uh I I'd like to go back and just look
briefly and explain what we're doing in
terms of several of the bills which we
did not do on Monday they would carry
forward to this session right here but
I'd like to speak to two of them right
now uh HB
1015 is relative to requirements for
literacy skill development in Elementary
grades um so that bill does carry
forward and I see we do have an
amendment I I'd like to know if we have
any other amendments coming forward on
that Bill yes yes we do so we're going
to hold off until the other amendments
we get them all here so we can have that
uh discussion the other bill which
wasn't taken care of was
1450 and that's relative to establishing
a commission on higher education
consolidation that's the bill which was
put in as a placeholder for the
Governor's tat executive order which was
passed and there was a a a a not a
commission but a task force which was
put together to uh look at uh issues
associated with the higher education in
terms of aligning have identifying
strategies to align some of these cost
saving efforts and and just looking at
the whole process that committee has
been task force has been meeting on
Fridays in fact we meet again this
coming Friday represent luno luno and I
are both on that along with
representation from the community
college system the HED University system
uh business industry Association and
being
basically chaired by uh Steve applebe
from the Department of Education who's
director of higher education that is
moving forward and coming out with some
real good recommendations and findings
so we have amending language which has
been approved by both systems and by
that group uh inviting the chancellors
to continue work and Reporting back to
the higher education study uh committee
which we already have in place however
the bill the amendment all of amendments
to that bill are being seen as
non-gain seeing that we're talking about
different sections of Statute we're not
talking necessarily consolidation we
aren't talking consolidation we aren't
talking merger we're looking at
strategies to uh address the issues
which we have at higher education and
coming up with some great strategies and
and so what we're going to have to do so
we won't be discussing 1450 today we
will be having a non-gain hearing at
9:00 on the 18th that is Monday morning
uh where that will be held and we will
have here helping to explain some of
that uh folks from the University system
community college system uh from that
executive uh the the governor's uh task
force to uh explain this amendment so
that that's where we are on that so none
of the bills from last Monday will be
discussed today so now we're looking at
the bills dealing with the qu operative
you school districts the merging all
that dealing with the structure
organization of of these uh these
particular uh uh methods of governing
education in the
state and I'm going to do this in such a
way we're going to introduce the you
know the first we will have discussion I
will invite discussion from sponsors if
they want to engage in this which I
think it will be very very helpful and
uh so with that in mind I'd like to
start right off with uh HB
1195 this bill is relative to allowing
school districts to approve
different apportionment methods for
school administrative unit cost so we're
not talking co-ops in this thing we're
talking about the school administrative
units saus and and an apportionment meth
methods which we have here so um 1195
everybody should try to open up that
1195 and of course as as usual I left
mine in the office and so I'm going to
jump up and get my copy of that bill I
hope everybody had a good week our day
off I had a wonderful day I learned how
to change a muffler on a vehicle that
was glaciated and Ice all through it and
chipping it off and trying to climb
underneath a RAV and drive it then 30
mil South to the mechanic to fix it but
it was
on
it's
F
okay
okay 1195 um so we have several bills
today that are dealing with seus so
let's let's maybe we'll try address
those you know together but this one
first um I'm going to open this up to
discussion so that
um these topics that we're dealing with
today are really important topics uh and
I I want to make sure that we're going
to you know uh try to get a direction
where we're going with these that's
going to be really beneficial for every
year I've been here there's been bills
on saus and a lot of bills on co-ops and
we're we're still having them come in
and and like a a retread Tire it keeps
coming around so 1195 open to discussion
right now is anybody want to discuss
this
1195 including a member of the public
well represent
Cordell thank you um I think there has
been some discussion about um the uh
abortion method in saus and um we had
testimony um from a written testimony
from uh the uh Board of
Selectmen um in
Newton um and confirmed in 194
C9 um that um the only apportionment
method in the uh statute is half
enrollment and half um uh equal
valuation yeah equalized valuation thank
you um so this just wants to open it up
um to other me methods that might be
worked out um within the
SAU um you know I'm not sure I can't
recall specific details of um what they
wanted to change or if there was
agreement on a method they wanted to
change it
to
um but uh you know I'm I'm certainly
open to um allowing greater flexibility
there I
think further discussion on that
thank you Mr chair I I brought this up
the other day and I haven't heard any um
any good argumentation as to why I would
be wrong about it and I would certainly
open to hearing why I'm wrong about this
but it does seem to me that if if
there's an agreement in place that that
localities have entered into to be under
one of these organizations under a
certain apportionment method
that then can be changed by a majority
vote it would seem that it could further
disadvantage certain localities that are
already possibly
disadvantaged um by virtue of a simple
majority vote in that is not in
accordance with the original agreement
that was entered into um again i' would
love to hear if there's any good reason
you yes represent Bon thank you Mr chair
um Mr desan is right here and you can
ask him
directly
sure again Paul to Shan I'm with the
town of Newington and addressed you back
in January and thank you very much for
the opportunity to speak with you again
uh to your specific uh question a very
good question um I believe though under
uh one 95
C2 it's one subsection 1-8 um there's a
planning committee that's voted to be
established that then would talk about
if if they were able to talk about um
abortions right now the statute is so
fixed you can't even talk about it um
because there is no agreement the
statute says it will be 1 half one2 so
there's never ever a discussion relative
to the apportionment um in the seu
situation and even if the comes back
with a recommendation to change that
abortion and it still needs a 3- fifths
U majority vote um by this dist member
school districts of the SAU so so it's
not as practical or easy as just you
know who who Who's the biggest thumb on
the scale so to speak uh it has to be a
super majority in order to uh enact
those type of changes so there has to be
a you know real mutual agreement as to
what that aort apportionment may be
other than the one half one half if this
enabling legislation is
enacted represent dry thank you and
thanks for taking my question um when we
talked about Cooperative school
districts on Monday morning we noticed
that a lot of the those agreements 955
6040 all those um but uh so I I agree
that it we should be able to talk about
those kind of things because obviously
they work in the real world but what we
noticed was missing how to get out of
that if he doesn't do it and maybe
requiring something um of that nature
would that work in this situation as
well this is not a co-op I know it's not
a co-op but I mean you're still in the
same situation you're you're you're in
some place maybe you don't like and how
do you how do you change it the the
process is the same under u u 95 C2 um
you start a planning committee the
committee does this study has a
recommendation then there's a vote on
the recommendation
and the recommendation only could be uh
adopted by 3 fifths um so so there's a
mechanism in place and I would also add
um from what I heard from Monday's
testimony seems like a lot of these
Cooperative school districts entered
into the agreements when they were kind
of new and fashionable I hope by you
know the many decades that we've
experienced uh we've all learned from
that uh and we would come back uh with a
much uh more practical uh solution at
least in the SAU situation uh that I'm
advocating for thank you thank you for
your
question
further yes represent M thank you Mr
chair as I understand this proposal is
basically an enabling
legislation so it doesn't prescribe how
it should be done but it actually
provides a greater opportunity for
people to look at different ways of
looking this rather than what is
currently prescribed in the law is that
correct that is exactly correct
represent repres Bel thank you Mr chair
I just wanted to POS a hypothetical and
I hope anybody can answer it as to as to
why this wouldn't be the case let's take
a hypothetical where we have 10 uh local
political divisions towns that are put
together into one of these groups and
they want to look at a different
apportionment method and the
apportionment method they look at it and
you have you have nine of the towns in
category that would be benefited um by
this and one town that would be severely
on the other side of things perhaps even
at thee let's say it shifts 90% of the
cost of business to one
town uh away from the other nine towns
uh and the other nine towns would
probably want to vote for that so what
recourse under that circumstance with
that one town who is now going to be
saddled with such a huge huge burden um
what what recourse would they have under
under this law if we passed it okay now
we also have Barrett who's been he's
been right through this whole thing you
ask represent vure so uh Barrett would
you come on up and sit beside there so
we have the school boards Association
here as well uh seeing we're trying
to get some because the represent beler
asked a real important question thank
you thank you much chair man lad good
morning members of the committee for the
record bar Christina from the school
boards Association representative beler
is I'm reading the bill um line three it
says as the constituent school districts
May approve person to RSA 194 C2 I'm
interpreting that as long in in addition
to the alternative budget methods in 194
c9a and B that in order for the
alternative method to be approved each
individual School District within the
SAU would have to approve it so I'm
going to take an example of sa67 which
is dun Barton and Bo Bo the the bo
voters would have to approve the
alternative method and the Dunbarton
alternative method at their respective
annual meetings in order for a a a
different me a different apportionment
method to be implemented I don't I'm not
interpreting the bills you would take a
totality of the votes SAU wide and the
plurality town could carry with whatever
they wanted that's how I'm interpreting
it that each individual town would have
to adopt it at their own local annual
meeting thank you is that an
interpretation or is that in statute so
um in in 194 C 194
C9 um it says you know each School
District this is alternative budget
procedure method for adoption each
School District within an SAU that is
composed of two or more districts may
vote to adopt the provisions of RSA 194
c9b to determine the means for adopting
the SAU budget by placing the question
on the warrant of their next annual
School District meeting so it says each
district this is again 194 c9a paragraph
1A each district places it on at their
annual at their annual
meeting the the the proposed bill is is
not as explicit as that but I mean I I I
think I would hope reasonable Minds
would interpret it the same way that we
were be that we're reading the
alternative methods in 194 C9 A and B
thank you yes represent luno
thank you thank you very much and and a
sort of a follow on question uh along
this sort of line of discussion um as
well if um if a um if a district wanted
to uh withdraw from the seu let's say
the aoran was not it was very
unfavorable to that District as
representative Belcher uh was was was
prop hypothetically um U proposing uh a
a District fall after a study and a plan
can
unilaterally remove itself from the
district with a from the seu with a
three-fifths vote is that correct the
decision to leave an SAU or withdraw
from an SAU is that District specific it
is not a vote SAU wide as it is with the
co-op thank you yeah thank good
clarification uh represent Terry oh uh
thank you uh gentlemen I'm on line four
here actually let's you begin at the end
of line three the schooled
administrative unit board may use such
other methods that's fine as the
approve what's the what is the Practical
meaning of
May I think you just explained that you
believe you would interpret that to mean
that each of the constituent school
districts would have to
approve so what is the operationally
here and functionally why is the word
may here rather than shall sure or
necessarily must right thank you for the
question representative I mean I'm I'm
I'm seeing that as just enabling
language I I understand your your
interpretation um but it's saying that
the school board may use the alternative
oh I see as the the SAU board may use
alternative may use other such methods
as a constituent school districts you're
saying did approve
or well wouldn't that be required isn't
that what we're talking about here all
school districts need to approve of this
then why is the word may there rather
than shall necessarily right I think if
if I understand if the constituent
districts are approving the alternative
method then the SAU board shall use that
method is that what you're trying to say
sir yes okay but the trigger is that
each of the districts has to approve the
the language needs to be worked on here
to clarify otherwise it's in my view and
I'm realizing I'm coming in later but
it's very ambiguous and could be easily
misinterpreted be May is permissive
typically and what we want here is is uh
is
definition that it is
required that each School District must
in order
for an alternative method to be employed
so and suiz you have where you are Paul
so you would read that last line four
going on to five such other methods as
con uh constituent school districts
approv pursuant to taking the May out
the second May
yes but but to be clear about it you
know must
approve
prior to i' rework I spent some time
reworking the language but I think we're
all clear on the school districts each
of the school districts must approve of
the the method before it can be
triggered it's not so so we we need to
get precise language here and I'm not
sure that just by removing the word may
satisfies I have I'd have to that thank
you and just to follow up on that very
good point I I would say I think the
problem in that language I see is
actually the tense because May approve
is speculative in this sense that
suggests something that may happen in
the future but this actually has to have
happened before so the language should
say have approved or just PL approved or
have approved is in like it's already
been done yeah yes past
tense further discussion representative
fellows um yes I'm trying to catch up
here so um I'm wondering if if there
would need to be any kind of process
like a public hearing on this a special
way to make sure the um voters
understand is that in statute or does
that need to be added thank you for that
question
U 195 C2 has a very extensive approval
process which includes public
hearings um both well open hearings uh
of the planning committee that's
established to to come up with an
alternative uh abortion or or whatever
alternative
uh agreement relative to the SAU uh when
their
uh plan is presented it's presented to
the school board the school board must
have a a public hearing uh on the
question uh and then the three- fifths
vote
occurs yes so you said 195 C2 excuse me
194 194 C can you say can you
so it requires a public can you tell me
all the things that are required what it
all the things that are required in
194c yeah it's subsections 1 through
eight yeah it's a lengthy process there
it talks about three fifths and all this
other so there's a lot to this
process and and the vote has to be what
three fifths three fifths three three
fifths of each
yes yeah Mr chair yes go ahead right and
and you know I I think we could go ahead
with with with this bill uh you know you
know 194 C2 is the method that's that's
used to determine apportionment and like
I like we you know talked about there's
always the parachute rip cord if if um
if a district uh doesn't like the um the
the result of of that and that's
completely up to the district um itself
so so uh you know I think um I I think
um um uh representative Terry has an
interesting interpretation of that but
uh but from a practical standpoint I
don't think an amendment's really
necessary to move this forward and if it
was it could be done in the Senate we
would have no thank you the the that
Amendment would simply just change the
tents of approved to approved well said
would it would it would basically say
the process for approval is C2 and CU
there is no other process for uh for
approval yeah so you don't have an
option of not using C2 right
right Is there further discussion
representative fellows yes I I would
just like to say that I worked at the
Department of Education for 32 years and
over that period I've seen a lot of um
districts want to withdraw from an SAU
and they and usually the reason is they
think that they're paying more than
their share of uh paying paying more
than their share but getting less than
their than a equal share from of
attention from the sa so saus have
broken up because of that I think that
that this maybe will would help some of
the saus Stay Together better because
they would have the option to say well
we understand understand why this town
that you know has 10% of the students in
paying 45% of the of the cost might want
to get out and it gives them the
opportunity to to adjust that so that
the that town would want to
stay okay is there a further discussion
from where we are on the bill right now
we have two folks sitting
here thank you very much I don't see any
further need appreciate your input today
so so back to the committee here as a
whole um I I I I've I've heard
two with that lines four and five um
changing the
tents and I I heard must but if you
write in approved you know that's a past
tense that means is done pursuant to
that um or I've heard the other
suggestion that it's good the way it
is so I guess where we are is that uh
I'm going to just what we're going to be
doing today do with these bills because
we have so very few of them um I'd like
to have you know and I've mentioned to
the ranking represent on the other side
we will take some caucuses throughout so
we can wind up and figure out where we
are so we're going to take a very brief
caucus right now do you want to do the
other well yeah yeah and it's represent
cordelli has another good point earlier
this morning we have been discussing
these these co-ops and them and Theus
with some folks for over an hour and we
have another bill here also dealing with
this uh 1579 yeah
1579 um Rel to the merging of school
administrative units so let's at the
um it it's dealing with the same
organization or the same in uh
governance structure but from a
different angle here so 1579 is relative
units chairman lad I actually have an
amendment for that okay we'll get that
in
okay Al righty uh representative pel you
you said you had a an amendment and is
that handed out to everybody coming
around now okay so we might want to look
at that before we you know get into the
meet on this in
discussion and for those that are new to
the committee today we're having this
these discussions a little bit with the
executive session seeing that we've had
107 bills we just have not had the time
to deal with some of the ins and outs on
bills which a little bit more time might
give us more information so that's what
we're doing and uh hopefully um this
making okay I think everybody has a copy
of that right now representative Pell
will you just walk out of the
room
okay good go ahead represent Celli yes
um I believe that um the main um change
in this was uh on line 8 changing the
1500 uh students to 12200 students and
here comes Pell uh represent Pell can
ball sorry thank you yes um the
amendment does just just um dropped down
the number of um the merging number the
sorry the number of students in the
merging districts to from 1500 to 12200
and that was based on um some
conversation that I that was heard
during the um committee hear the initial
hearing so since then I've heard um
maybe why have any number at all because
maybe some smaller districts um would be
interested in merging and I would have
no problem with them mending that to
eliminate that the whole purpose of this
bill was just to
encourage districts to merge because um
the number of Administrators has just
been increasing significantly more than
the number of um direct teaching staff
to the students and we want to make some
of those changes I have information to
pass around also on the number of um ad
administrators the number of pupils per
administrators and this is information
we got we received from the Department
of Education um for
example
um this is coming around but some of the
districts are significantly topheavy
so
um for example colbrook has 43 students
per SAU
staff um London d
in contrast has 2117 pupils per SAU
staff um I think Manchester if I believe
best yeah Manchester was let's see White
Mountain Regional has up 150 students
per SAU
staff so there's quite a discrepancy now
Mar Mach Valley has 267 pupils per SAU
staff so that's the far right column of
the um spreadsheet that I'm passing
now okay so we can discuss this right
now um I I guess I'm in concurrence with
representative panel that I prefer to
see no number 1500 1200 I like to see no
number seeing that there are many
schools in my saus in my neck of the
woods which have small numbers to begin
with it' be good to see even a couple of
them joining and it wouldn't come up to
even a thousand kids but the issue which
we're having in the North country is
that these saus cover a whole lot of
territory and we have folks that for
example the SAU office provides special
education services and other you know
Services which are are delivered to all
the participating towns or districts in
that
SAU sometimes we have people driving 60
Mi one way and so that creates a need
for more staff if you're going to have
that service provided uh when it's
needed in these schools especially when
it comes to special education so that's
why you're going to see some lower
ratios for the you know the those
smaller districts those saus which have
a lot of territory and C Brook C
certainly has a lot of territory up that
way so that's just a brief comment right
there represent
Ry thank you I'd like to itate re
iterate that yes it's going to come up
in planfield and cornish's um Town
meetings on Saturday um and between the
two districts we have 300 students so I
would be um inclined to go with no
number represent
cordelli so am am I correct if we
eliminate um lines eight and nine the
number then we could also eliminate uh d
and
e from a new Amendment
I think e could be amended to line 24 on
the amendment would be um change to all
school districts served by the newly
merged school administr administrative
unit shall be eligible for the
consolidation Grant correct yes thank
you representative Damon and then
representative
luno thank you Mr chair I have a
question on the amendment different from
what we've been
discussing um it seems true to remove
line 9 and 10 from the original bill in
regards to specifying that this doesn't
it references pre-existing Co-op school
districts why was that
removed thank you I heard comments from
multiple people that there was no reason
not to include Cooperative districts so
we removed it that was from the doe and
from um other organizations that gave us
input after the initial bill had been
submitted follow
yes so just to clarify then existing
Cooperative school districts would
qualify to consolidate under this Bill
yes yes like I said after after we
submitted this original Bill we received
feedback from other and so that's why we
have this amendment in fact when
representative Tierney presented the
bill we he came with an amendment
already thank you per s
luno thank you very much Mr chair and um
and and thank you representative
peternell for the uh for the amendment
here I would um um I I agree that the
amendment's going in the right direction
I agree with eliminating lines 8 and N
um I'd also suggest eliminating lines 10
and 11 uh so that saus can uh can make
their own um organizational um uh and uh
and man uh management decisions and um
and and and and eliminating lines 24 25
26 that all goes along with that
um uh um I I I think the uh the
financial incentive is is is strong and
that's that's important um I'm concerned
about the
survivability of the uh of The Proposal
with the with the financial cost in it
but i' I'd like to see the fin I'd like
to see the 200 stay uh the $200
incentive stay in there um but um but
I'm just putting it out there as a as a
concern um I I think the the honestly
the most important piece is that um is
that the uh C2 is is is basically
amended to say that mergers are possible
as well not just creation withdrawal and
things like that so
um thank you Mr chair further further
discussion yes thank you I um disagree
with eliminating lines 10 and 11 because
part of the purpose of
um this bill is to limit the number of
administrative staff and there is a time
frame this will sunset on July 1st 2026
so that's why I'm not overly concerned
with the longevity of the
grants on um line 17 y
okay further discussion on it representa
Cornell well lines 10 and 11 when it
says have only one superintendent or
person responsible for superintendent
superintendent because if you have a
district all the size of man if they end
up being the size of Manchester and this
chart is actually wrong because we have
more than one assistant superintendent
for almost 12,000
students once again this is a bill which
is
allowing decisions to made be made at
the local
level
and well well that's that's what I'm
addressing um so you know I I'm I I
think the bill itself is absolutely
needed we need to be able to merge these
districts for a lot of different reasons
um you're still going to have huge
Transportation costs you're going to
still have when you're merging you're
going to have to figure out which
buildings are going to be the receiving
elementary kids which are the middle of
the high school kids so there's going to
be a whole lot going on there and when
you do merge districts together you have
various New Towns and districts there
walking in a superintendent shoes you
know you're going to be out every darn
night for some kind of a school board
meeting in one of those districts so
it's they went through trying to
consolidate over in Vermont and what
they found out that even through
consolidation their administrative costs
did not shrink yeah it was just a given
and represent Leon um thank you thank
you Mr chairman um we actually have a
bit of a real word example of what
happens with consolidation and
administrative roles the dairy is now
going to be outdated because we have
closed one of our schools da Village
School and there were two new
administrative positions made in the SAU
and in order to allow the principal and
vice principal to stay on um so we need
to make sure that the very compassionate
idea of trying to make sure that people
keep their jobs um isn't outweighed by
the fact that people need to keep their
homes uh by having an appropriately
scaled
Administration and um I think that the
line language on lines nine and 10 that
may make it so that it's only
appropriate to do this merger for some
school districts but the question is is
it better to enable this for some school
districts where it's a good fit or try
and have a solution that works for
everybody and just keep repeating the
same challenges we've seen through all
of our attempts to consolidate uh we
just we're going through this right now
and everything the school board wanted
was uh shot down on the on the ballot
yesterday so we want to make sure that
whatever we we do going forward and
whatever we enable for the districts
doesn't cause more confusion within the
towns represent cordelli and then
representative Luna thank you I think
lines 10 and 11 11 really just State um
what is in statute elsewhere and that um
you can have a superintendent but as
long as you have someone to perform
superintendent Services that's fined
also according to current statute so I I
I don't really see the the problem with
10 and 11 because it's um as I said it's
a restatement I as I read it of current
law repres luno thank you
um yeah I
I if it's if it's already in current law
somewhere else I think that's reason to
take out lines 10 and 11 um currently I
think lines 10 11 would um would in some
cases prohibit a uh a district from uh
from merging with another SAU and if the
goal here is to encourage districts to
uh to merge have multiple districts
served by a single SAU having
restrictions on that um uh would seem to
be problematic uh in fact um in fact the
way the way the law stands right now A
District could uh leave its current or
you know abandon its own SAU you know
following a study following the process
and C2 and join with another um merge
with a with a with another SAU under
current law a district could do that
right now it's not specified but they
could do that right now now with this
new law they would only be able to merge
uh with another seu with all of these
limitations in place with all of these
restrictions in place so for a lot of
districts they'd say no you know what we
can't do it we um for for whatever
reason we don't meet the the 12200
although I think we're all in agreement
to uh to eliminate that but um but uh I
I I I would I you know current law
provides the flexibility that's there if
this law is intended to encourage
merging it does it with the $200 per
pupil incentive and uh and really that
should be that should be all that's in
here further further discussion
representa pen then representative Damon
thank you um this is an incentive Grant
and the incentive is to limit the top
down Administration and so I
100% disagree with removing lines 10 and
11 because that is the entire purpose of
this bill then then how would how
wa okay let's just put your hand up
please okay uh represent Damon then
represent
Luna thank you so I think in life one
size fits-all generally is a
falsehood and line 10 and 11 attempts to
be one size fits all but depending on
the student population of the district
the geography the number of communities
it may simply not be realistic to have
only one superintendent so I really or
superintendent level of services I would
really agree with removing lines 10 and
11 so that more districts can seriously
great representative luno was next no no
then representative cordelli and then
representative pno per me
I had my hand oh repr Le I didn't see it
go ahead repres
Le um following up on rep what rep
penell said and what rep luno said
currently districts can
merge
and have as me and do it however they
want and have the um superintendence and
Etc as they want the idea with this bill
is in addition to what they could
already
do if they want this
grant they're going to agree to limit
their superintendent to just one so this
is just providing another way of merging
and the point is to reduce
that top superintendent you know the top
administrative section so if you want
the money you limit if you don't want
the the money do whatever you want
represent pel if the districts already
have two superintendents and they
merge how can you have more than one
superintendent because you have to have
one
boss we only have one
Governor but so they they might create
new positions for assistant
superintendence but there's still only
one superintendent for the
SAU
represent Luna thank thank you Mr chair
so so I think the the concern I and I
agree you're you're only going to have
one superintendent the same way a
company only has one CEO but you may
have um uh more than one person
responsible for superintendent duties
because uh those dut the super you can
see the superintendent Duties are
enumerated and I don't even remember the
section of law but but it's like a mile
long you know it's as long as my arm and
so you might have multiple people doing
that there' still only be one
superintendent but um but so the that's
you know that that I think is another
reason why 10 and 11 should be
eliminated lines 10 and 11 should be
eliminated the other thing that I think
is is um
um may not be uh a correct
interpretation is although the law and
although current law C2 does not talk
about mergers this section is about
mergers and I think any merger would be
limited to the terms in this in this
section so unless you followed all the
restrictions in here you'd not be able
to merge saus you would not have the
benefit of the uh the Omission in
existing law uh with respect to um to
mergers this would be the the section
that that directs how mergers would be
done further discussion yes represent
thank
you I'm wondering if this perhaps could
be resolved by
removing in line
11 or person responsible for
superintendent duties so the bill would
still require only one superintendent
one one boss one
CEO but it would not State a limit on
how the broad long arm of superintendent
Duties are accomplished what number of
other positions there might
be represent belra and then represent uh
dry thank you Mr chair this has been a
productive debate and as we've gone
through it uh something has kind of
clicked with me that is a cause for some
some lesser concern that I think could
be easily fixed um I like the idea
behind what we're trying what this is
trying to accomplish the the trouble I
see is that there isn't always a rhyme
or a reason to the expansion of
bureaucracy even as we've had the
reduction in the total number of
students enrolled we've had more
administrative positions being created
my concern is if we encourage with a
financial incentive towns that come
together or seus that come together and
merge we might actually have an
equalization in the opposite direction
toward a greater bureaucracy instead of
a lesser bureaucracy so i' I'd very much
like to see uh a minor amendment made
that only makes the financial incentive
available if the merger results in a net
staff Ron Dr you were next up thank you
I was just trying to find the bill that
we are also looking on that defines that
a person can take over the
responsibilities of superintendent
without being the superintendent and
just think adding that to the mix as
we're discussing
it yeah we discussed that with single
school districts uh and that is the
principal who has a master's degree but
just because a master's degree does not
necessarily guarantee you being able to
take over the superintendent Services
has to be reviewed by the department to
ensure that within that master's degree
the courses that are necessary for those
services are there if they're not there
so it's uh I think we went through that
and that might be a person that's
running the
other SAU right yes you're correct uh
represent cordelli uh thank you my
suggestion would be
um to uh change lines 10 and 11 uh to
read the proposed merger merg Su school
administrative unit shall have only one
superintendent or Personnel responsible
for superintendent duties pursuant to
194 C5 Roman 2A which is the statute um
that talks about uh superintendent
Services being performed uh by one or
more administrative Personnel for or
part-time or Services independently
contracted can you repeat the um RSA
you
okay any further discussion represent
Damon Mr chair would it be appropriate
to ask to hear from Mr Christina on
this I don't know if he has anything
wants to inut to us do you have a
specific question no I just like his
perspective yeah we're open to it thank
you you're
welcome
thank you chairman L good morning
members of the uh committee again I you
say Roman I don't without a specific
question um I mean and I'll be honest
with you I kind of multitasking back
there I was not listening intently to
every word that was being set up here I
despite the fact that I enjoy all my
time here sometimes I have other things
I have to get to as well respectfully so
I mean you know I mean I don't you know
if if if nhba didn't take a position on
the bill if there's a if there's an
incentive that can be you know if if
this committee can find language to
create an incentive for saus to to merge
and perhaps cut administrative costs so
be it I think money money is always a
great incentive you know it's usually
the best incentive um but I mean I don't
I don't we don't have a position on the
on the on the bill per se representative
cordelli I did hear you sort of mirror
the language from C5 that would that
would be fine um I should just as as a
point of background there is one SAU in
the state that has two superintendant
I'm not talking about an assistant
superintendent they have two
superintendant sa53 which is Pembrook
Deerfield Epsom Chai Chester and
Allenstown they have two
superintendant um one superintendent um
is basically responsible for Pembrook
and Deerfield and the other
superintendent is responsible for the
for the three other districts in that in
that SAU but their their co-s
superintendence if you will but that's
the only one that I'm that I'm aware of
in the
state this state is really got it all
doesn't it wow yeah that is a wow yeah I
agree you know I I think that
representative Celli's suggestion here
to replace that with 194 C5 Roman 2A is
good that's fine and I think that would
just work in fine there for that that
line that we're you know we don't want
to be telling their they want to merge
it's a great idea to merge because
there's going to be a lot of cost
savings hopefully
hopefully but um it's it's it's allowing
that to occur right and there's an you
have to have the incentive you're going
to have to come up with some incentive
to get districts to do it or else we're
going to see the breaking apart of saus
like we've seen the last 20 years or so
yeah yes you have a clarifying question
yes thank you very much Mr chair and and
thank you Mr Christina so with
representative cordell's proposed C5 um
language uh
f after the part that says um have only
one superintendent comma and then you've
got the C5 language in there would would
that provide the um the I I guess
administrative flexibility to make to
for a district to have a school business
officer responsible for the
superintendent financial
responsibilities yeah thank you I think
it would um representative uh luno you
mentioned the laundry list of respon
superintendent responsibilities under C4
yeah uh representative Cordell you
mentioned that you know or person who
can provide those Services the the
laundry list of stuff that's done under
C4 we know it's not the superintendent
that's doing that it's delegated you
know the first one I think is payroll we
know the superintendent is not is not
running payroll there's a business
office that's taking care of that so you
know we've always said there's an
inherent authority of that list in C4 um
where the superintendent has Authority
just either not even statutory Authority
but just inherent authority of the way a
business is operated to delegate to the
rest of the administrative staff or the
building level
staff okay thank you thank
you representative
Miler thank you I mean this has been an
interesting discussion I think it's
important to note that if somebody's
going to merge my sense is they're
looking at an economy of scale
here so you're not
the merging and having increased costs
is duplicative of what the intent is so
I think the perhaps represent cordelli
suggestion would solve at least that
thing I I can't imagine that if you're
going to merge two districts you're
going to increase the management of that
because you're trying to decrease the
management of it and so I think that uh
obviously this is an important piece
because I think we do need to look to
see where we can have mergers of school
districts across the state but I think
we're kind of denying the local decision
making around this is why they're doing
this and it's not to increase the cost
but it's to decrease the cost and that
obviously has to deal with your Topline
management and the uh cost for those
respective
positions and this all puts the onus on
the school districts that are merging to
do a feasibility study that's going to
be sustainable into the future and give
these you know efficiency of scale that
you're talking about and so I I think
this is a a great idea and I think
representative pel has is right on the
course here and I think with the
additions that we've talked about I I'm
prepared to try to move forward with it
myself yes represent Leia um thank you I
just wanted to bring the bring us back
to the real world example the voters of
Dair thought that we'd have less
overhead by closing a school and that's
why they supported it but the overhead
has not decreased so we shouldn't assume
that all school boards will actually
take that as their mandate to decrease
the overhead while merging unfortunately
that doesn't always happen so we need to
make sure that when we enable something
we include the appropriate
protections representative Fells you had
your hand up too I believe I just um I'm
thinking that you might want to give
some consideration to situations where
you have those really small school
districts uh examp Hill would be an
example they were part of the sa with
Franklin but they pulled out of that a
few years ago and if they want to merge
back with Franklin or if they wanted to
um merge with
Newfound so they've got 64
students I don't know if you want to
treat those differently or um the other
possibility
is uh as you know Bridgewater and Hein
want to pull out of
Newfound so if they do that and they set
up for one or two years their own SAU
and then they merge with another one do
you want to have any um special language
for those situations there there's talk
about merging throughout this state
there's talk about withdrawal throughout
this state um it's been discussed in my
community havil Co-op wants a pull out
of sa23 they think they're going to save
money um it's Warren wants to pull out
of sa23 and go with Plymouth you got all
this stuff going on and so I think these
are local decisions I believe this gives
the road map for those local decisions
to be made and I think that's where it
is um we've also put in school building
Aid you know building Aid grants are
looked at in terms of consolidation
efficiency of scale and all that if
you're consolidating yes we're willing
to go that direction but we don't want
to go
expand um
so is there any more discussion on this
because we got a break and have a caucus
here we have two bills which I think
think we have some direction represent
Bon it's just a technical suggestion um
the the point of reference that you made
to 194 C5 I'm just C curious why you we
wouldn't just um reference
194 uh C4 which actually describes the
duties as there a reason I 195 C5 refers
back to 190c C4 it does I'm just curious
you know we we have another bill
elsewhere in this legislative body where
they're looking at Rec codifying all the
education
statutes and you know and it's because
we have done this we we've referenced
all this stuff we have so many links and
and entanglements it's it's just a mess
and you know how we ever are going to
correct
that I don't know but uh so I'd like to
try to do this the simplest way we can
do it and and and get get us on the road
to supporting these these school
districts so let's take a caucus right
now for a few moments
and these two bills yes because these
are the SAU bills uh do we have another
SAU bill I don't think so represent
spills spr your bill was what a co-op
Co-op co-ops yeah I thought so okay so
let's take a few moments here go discuss
this um if we're going to be wanting to
make amendments then we want to get
through the caucuses really quickly here
so we can get these amendments made and
hopefully get them done over the Lunch
Period so we can come back and and have
something in place to take action
genda
okay we'll look at 1195
microphone
e
okay I'd like to get going here on on
these
bills
represent Cordell ran over off with my
bill here I still ran off of it or
okay okay what's number on the second uh
1579 yeah okay on HB 155 uh 15 what 79
I think we're all pretty much on the
same page as what we had discussed here
we're taking out uh part one there where
it references the number of Kids 1 1200
1500 take that out the second part we're
referencing the statutory uh reference
that represent cordelli had alluded
to and and getting down in the bottom
part of that
were I I don't have that exact L leaving
D yeah leaving no we're taking we're
leaving D in yes D staying in and then
uh part e we're simply saying all school
districts served by the newly merged
school administrative unit shall be
eligible for the cons consolidation
Grant taking all that in between stuff
out the number referencing the number of
students so leing be in or speaking d n
d n d is in while you're on the language
chair yeah represent it's not
merger this a mer this a merger gr not a
consolidation
Grant 26 I word 26 and 15 yeah we're
talking about the merger Grant yeah well
on 15 it says a consolidation Grant oh
okay well you may want to change that
merger because it's an SE
merger well the same with on 21 then
what's it say up in the in the in the
topic of the bill mer yeah up here in
mer it it we can you
know it's probably merger because merger
is in the title of the bill too yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think we're good that's
26 well yeah 21 and six
26 21 okay so consolidation out mergers
in y okay good okay let's
get but that's just a
verb
cons that's that's fine that that's
right say that's a verb
correct okay uh
1195 uh relative allowing school
districts to approve different
apportionment methods for school
administrative unit costs when we
discussed out there a second ago there's
a little confusion we're all on the same
page what we need to do is break that
sentence out on lines three through five
into two sentences
and the first sentence would read
something to this effect in addition to
the method of apportionment set forth in
paragraph one school administrative unit
board may consider other methods
period Then the method of apportionment
to be used shall and then we go on you
know have been approved by the
constituent districts pursuant
to so they can look at all these
different areas they want to look at but
what they do is has to be done in
conjunct they have to be approved by the
constituent districts using the past
approved so is there any
any oh two sentences there be two
sentences the uh the method of
apportionment to be used shall
have been approved by the constituent
school districts pursuant to RSA
194c
2 is that
it oh come on now I got it the method of
the deportment to be used shall have
been shall have been approved by the
constituent stool
districts and then we have to say
something more U to pursuant to the RSA
that's there yeah and it's a it's it's
shall in the second sentence they have
to do what y we're all good with that we
can go ahead and then because we do want
to get you know the next discussion by
12 o'clock I'm just wondering if the
word all be in that second sentence by
district
it it can but I think that's specified
in 194c
to yeah yeah yeah I think we're good
with
it that's all in there
yeah Al righty so what I'd like to do
now is uh represent spilsbury's been
here waiting all day to talk about his
bill and I know folks have to be out of
here by 12 so I'd like to offer you that
opportunity to try to give us some
rationale behind why this
bill and why you've done some of the
things within it we'll get that I'll
have to get to the the page number here
with that bill it's uh
16 is that 1642 whichever one you want
to take up first I'm the I'm the
co-sponsor of 1383 and the prime sponsor
on 1481 1483 in
I can take them in the order that you
have them listed here and be very
brief okay so you're the Prime on 1481
yes okay and 1383 are you a co-sponsor
in that one co-sponsor yeah well let's
start right and work down through them
okay
1383 okay 1383 a quick background I had
put in and LSR request today after uh
representative culcom uh we both wanted
to address the question of a Cooperative
School District with multiple
pre-existing districts where there are
board seats assigned to a specific
District but the member seated for that
uh Town seat gets elected at
large that's what lines um 15 through 18
do it was my impression at your hearing
that there are other elements of
Representative cul's
bill that raised extraneous questions
for example on line
nine uh this bill
deletes the uh alternative of having all
members elected at
large and that wasn't uh something I was
pursuing uh also down towards the bottom
in line 26
uh representative Cam's bill would
change from a nonpartisan ballot to
official ballot under RSA 671 that again
was not my agenda and so in assessing
the tone of the hearing representative
culcom and I have collaborated I spoke
to her as recently as yesterday she's at
another committee this morning and I
have uh I mentioned this to uh chairman
lad on Monday I have asked OSS to revise
uh to to give me an amendment which has
not been turned out of O us yet as of
this moment uh that would simply make
the change in 15 to
18 so in other words where you have a
board seat designated for a pre-existing
District only the voters residing in
that town could vote for their own
representative and I'd like to just give
you an illustration of how this plays
out in Fall Mountain we have charl town
with about 45% of the students uh
Walpole with about 32% of the students
alad uh around 18 uh and uh two very
small towns aworth and Langdon that are
about seven or
8% we have had two times in the last
four years where a charl town contested
seat went to candidate a amongst
Charlestown voters but then the other
towns which collectively have 55% of the
vote choose candidate B that's a bad
result and it leaves Charlestown feeling
like their choice didn't Prevail but I I
feel just as strongly and sympathetic
towards the small towns why should
Charlestown with a population of
4,800 be able to overwhelm and dictate
to aworth within population of 800 who
their representative is so I don't think
this is something that plays in the
hands of a large Town versus a small
town I think it's just as important for
the small towns which are not in my
district um I feel I feel it treats them
both the same way so very simple
proposition if the amendment helps you
clear away the other issues in this bill
I just wanted you to have an alternative
that goes straight to the heart of that
one issue are there any questions
of represent spillsbury
does this get rid of at
large so the bill you have in front of
you gets rid of at large the amendment
I've asked to prepare does not go to
that and you know we can prepare another
amendment if that's something you do
want to include I just wanted to make
alternative yes representative
leus so when you said it doesn't get rid
of that did you change the word from
May so so the way the way that the law
currently did you put an or in there
it's a list of options and there's an or
at the end of each one there wasn't to
begin with that's what I ask and I would
say that my Amendment
also in line 6 to8 the law currently
says shall be limited to the
Alternatives contained herein
and representative cul's Bill changes
that to by the following requirements I
think
that's an error and so my Amendment
reinstates the language Alternatives
contained here in it's intended to be an
election thank you how do you deal with
a situation where you're let's say you
have a a board of seven people from
various
districts six are taken up maybe it's a
four uh
two and this other one you only have two
districts
there
is how are you going to sign that out is
that going to be at large voted by both
or or even as a Third District uh I'm
concerned about one man the law allows
for an for a a mix of town specific
seats and at large seats and that's the
way it's handled for example in in our
district where each of the five towns
regardless of their size has only one
rep assigned to them and then there are
two out llarge seats and that's where
the balance gets adjusted does that
address your question so the atlarge
seat is always going to be a
districtwide
election and and by the way just to give
you an analogy today if there is a
warant article to withdraw a certain
quantity funds from existing Capital
reserves it's set up in our district
where only the residents of that town
get to vote on the expenditure in that
town so there's already a mechanism for
separating out Town
interests yeah those Capital costs are
often times on a different formula than
than the other we've been talking about
right here
luno thank you Mr chair but but um but
but as far as other Financial interests
like the budget that gets voted on at
the co Co-op district meeting and
residents of all the towns that that
comprise that Co-op can go to that
meeting and vote on the the budget orb
if they're they're an SP2 um exactly
correct which occurred yesterday yes
right right so everybody gets a a one
person one vote uh you know type of type
of um
um ability to approve a um uh or vote on
a budget vote on a budget but but but in
this case when it comes to the the
um the the
town um the the the the person from from
each of the towns who who may be on the
co-op board and this is
um uh on on the uh the Roman C I'm
looking at the law the um the bill is as
initially um introduced in Roman 3 so so
where you're where you're suggesting
that that only the voters in the
town so Roman Roman 1 addresses at large
um situation R Roman 3 is specifically
addressing a
situation where um members represent a
pre-existing District district and so
all this change of language is modifying
is in that instance where there is a
seat representing a pre-existing
district and the change is to take that
away from being an atlarge election and
make it only the the res and that's my
point unlike unlike the the the vote by
the by all of the the people who live
within the co-op District to vote on on
a budget and and and unlike the current
law which requires all of the voters all
the voters who live in the co-op
District to vote on all of the
Schoolboard members that may be there
may be some serving at large there may
be some serving from each of the member
towns of the co-op so all of the members
get to vote on all of the Schoolboard
members who are now you know would
comprise the school board of the
district that I live in you'd have in
some instances only the member only the
voters from each Town voted on the
whoever's going to be the representative
from their town to the board so a small
town with let's say um um let's say a
thousand voters um would uh would vote
on a member and a larger town with let's
say 4,000 voters would vote on their
their one member so if I'm living in the
larger town I don't get as much say on
the the the the board uh because my
board member is you know was elected
through by a constituency of 4,000 as
opposed elected by a constituency of
1,000 and um and that that I think sort
of departs from you know if you're a
member of a
co-op wouldn't wouldn't would you know
if I'm living in a co-op wouldn't I be
interested in weighing in on all the
members who are who are serving on my
school board you may have that
preference to weigh in and your town
might have that preference but that
gives the dominant town the opportunity
to control the outcomes in all five
towns I'm telling you I'm asking for
this bill from the perspective of repres
of living in the town that's got the
largest population but I think it's even
more valuable to the little towns that
my town can
overwhelm okay F further discussion
represent
cordelli oh yeah I thought you sound I
was just going to say our school
district is similar and I do represent
one of the larger towns and I agree 100%
I do not see anything fair about the
town of wolfboro determining who
effingham's representative is on the
school board I think Effingham should
determine who they want to represent
their town on the school
board this a smaller town and they
should be able to elect their board
member specifically in addition to the
at large members that all of the towns
on that that concept is used in some
other states and what they do for
example across on on the other side of
the line with Maine they have a thousand
points and then they take and find some
kind of a ratio so you might have a vote
at the outcome of 4.76 for this and 3
point something you know other words you
you don't get a full member because you
only have 40 or 50 kids in your
town and so you're given a a voting
ratio in accordance with that out of
those thousand points and it's it's a
convoluted system that's a weighted
system that's used in some communities
some states
um if if I can suggest an analogy
there's a difference between the
Congress which is proportional to
population and the Senate which
guarantees that all states whether small
or large have an equal weight of two
this is essentially uh you know hybrid
where you have five members serving that
Senate purpose and you have two at large
serving that house purpose now how many
are at large and how many are by town I
think it's going to be a construct of
the individual District we're we're
going to have to call a break right here
because there's some folks have to leave
at 12:00 today so we're going to take a
break right now are you going to be
hanging around here a little bit today
okay thank you very much pursue this
Katie can you get the uh amending
language going for the the one bill you
have and are you doing the other one I
draft we're going for lunch we come back
at Mr chairman meeting some people have
a meeting starting right now okay yeah
yeah if I if I could just mention that's
the only one of the four bills on which
I'm suggesting an amendment and uh bar
Christina and I have had conversation
during lunch and I don't think he's
objecting to the other three bills Okay
so are you going to have that amending
language on this one we just
did okay thank you thank
you the
15 Barrett and I had conversation during
your caucus and he said that he had no
objection to the other three
bills is that
1195 yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
so see oh here let me take my copy and
I'll write it over to my cop the my
screen
um
e
okay we're going to go ahead with this
afternoon's exact sessions and the first
one we have up here is 1383
and yeah 1383 do you have an amendment
you okay we have a uh an opportunity to
start here in 1383 we have for
discussion purposes right now because
we've been discussing and I hope we can
get this done quickly uh representative
SPS spillsbury you're not a member of
the committee but this is your amendment
of course a Committee Member can
introduce that but would you like to
just one more time briefly explain the
changes you have on line 18 and
19 thank you very much for giving me the
opportunity so this essentially undoes
the other changes that were proposed in
1383 they're restor the statutory
language is restored so the only change
you're looking at on line 18 and 19 is
specifically to provide where there are
pre-existing districts assigned a rep to
that District it's the res the voters
resident in that town that get to vote
and those assigned seats by town are not
at large this does not change the fact
that there can still be at large
seats okay thank you very much represent
McDonald thank you Mr chair just a
clarification question this amendment
replaces the bill other than the
effective date is that
correct yes thank you further any other
questions of the
representative not say so let's get the
discussion amongst ourselves now
that okay who would like to put forth a
motion here we I'll okay representa
cordelli would you please put forward a
motion give me a
sure okay do you need a caucus okay a
caucus has been requested so we're going
to take a 5 10 minute break here for
you
help
all
e
and that's what I recall also and as I
recall my motion was going to be ought
to pass and I'll second
it we have a motion made by represent
cordelli and second this is right yeah
uh represent lad the OTP
1383 and and represent representative
Cordell thank you recognize yes um and I
would like to um uh propose not to pass
on the amendment that was just handed
it discussion from the maker of the
motion uh thank you um I I think the
important thing that the uh Amendment
does um is leave leaves things in place
except for the provision that
um Town pre-existing District
Representatives should be elected by
people within their own District rather
than by everyone in the entire uh
Cooperative district and that's been uh
my main goal also so uh I happy to U
pass
e
thanks uh a question to anybody that
might be bble to answer it um if um if a
district is currently um operating under
Roman 4 the the the paragraph that's
being amended
would would their method of voting
change uh with the enacting of this um
you know with this becoming law or would
it have to go back to the um the co-op
or the members for a three-fifths vote
to um for the
change I I guess is the change
retroactive or is it
prospective I I would think that it's
prospective so it's prospective meaning
they would have to vote by three fifths
to adopt
no
think
there's no I mean I thought
representative cordelli said yes it's
prospective right with the next election
what no because what the way the reason
so these these
options are options that
are that are put in the Articles of
agreement
in the co-op articles agreement so they
were if if Roman 4 was incorporated into
the article agreement for all existing
articles of agreement that use Roman 4
it would be referring to the existing
language not the language that's
proposed to change so
so if if if this amendment were to pass
and the bill were to pass and become law
would would the articles of agreement
refer to the old language or would they
automatically change right away to the
new
language I would think that the if the
way it reads right now of course you
might have somebody that's domiciled in
your particular District that's been
elected by way of at large
vote this would changes so that the who
shall be elected by their own District
so yes I think it's I think it's fair
that there be a person elected from that
particular District that's housed down
no that that's not that's not what my
question is Mr chair so so look on line
six of the of of the amendment it's it's
part of current law um that such bylaws
and articles of agreement shall be
limited to the Alternatives contained
herein where applicable so that's Romans
Roman 1 2 3
4 five
well six and seven but if if um if the
Articles of Incorporation
currently call out Roman
4 then does it do the do the terms of
the Articles of Incorporation change by
the law changing or do they have to make
an affirmative decision to change it to
update it to the new law I would say
they don't have to do anything seeing
that you look at item number five Roman
five
so long as you're following one man one
you know vote you're good yeah but they
this this no this clearly doesn't do one
man one vote this is very different than
that but but we we talked this morning
about retroactive laws versus
prospective laws and um and for it to be
retroactive that's that's some I mean
that was something in our conversation
this
morning
okay um
this set of
options excuse me I was going to comment
to your comment your question this set
of
options will become current law but
there is no way that this set of options
will change anybody
else's
current um
bylaws unless they unless is so voted
pursuant to RSA
6719 so all this is doing is giving
another option that if they want to
change it they may change it but it
doesn't Force anybody to change to
that that would be my understanding as
okay so thank you so
therefore if what representative leus
has just
indicated is what's
meant and please correct me if I'm
wrong this bill only accomplishes what
the sponsor is trying to accomplish if
read
thank you I'm going to respond briefly
two ways the
intention is that this changes the terms
of the fourth option so that any
Town automatically as a result of this
legislation that currently elects by
prior District has to now vote in this
way does not require local vote go back
to line
um
seven and you'll see there's a semicolon
in the middle of that
line so this is saying the number
composition method
Etc um has to is limited to the
Alternatives contained where
applicable stop it a
semicolon the phrase following the sem
semicolon stands on its own and provided
further that no Cooperative School
District in existence on August 22nd
1971 shall be required to conform here
to unless it is so voted pursuant to RSA
that unless it is so voted only pertains
Proviso thank you Mr chair this
situation we're talking about here is
exactly what my Cooperative district is
we have something like eight eight
members of the school board and there's
one person from each of the eight towns
so right now yesterday when I went into
the ballot Booth I had eight boxes eight
situations and that where I could vote
and my town and every other
one so person I would I would like to
see our district switch to what this
amendment does but I don't want to take
away the option for another dist
District like this or maybe the majority
of people in my district like it the way
it is I'm wondering if what we need is
just add another number in here leave
leave four the way it is and add a new
for
I I agree with representative fellows
that uh what this does is it uh changes
option four it doesn't leave option four
as an option as it currently exists it
changes it and my question would be if
you are currently operating under the
present form of option
4 and it changes to something different
and your articles of agreement site
option four as it presently
exists do you then are you then left
without a method of voting and you have
to choose one of the
current options four
options five well there's there there's
five as well
but
they I'm just going to pick up when you
say that's kind of like or anything else
that's mutually agreeable kind of that
like we do in some in other cases so
that's your bigger option I just want to
bring us to six7 1 colon 9 which is
referenced up here it's just one
sentence any Cooperative School District
organized under any of the provisions of
RSA 195 that's what we're talking about
or pursuant to any special act which
also we're talking about May at any
regular or special meeting vote to
change the number composition method of
selection and terms of office of members
of board of the district in accordance
with the provisions of
195 19
so it can take it we can as soon as this
takes place people can change things if
they want to so and I think all of them
are covered because I think we have
Roman numer five is that catch all yeah
so represent Hall thank you I yeah I
agree with this thinking down here you
haven't given I know representative Le
she said this gives us another option it
doesn't give us another option gives us
an alternative option so to give us
another option you would add one more
Roman numeral you would keep four and
then add one that says with this new
language says in the
you so I'm I'm not clear on how my town
if they decide or um Cooperative decided
if they wanted to keep it the way it is
now for four how that goes forward
because specifically in five it says one
man one vote I get I get to vote eight
times so because I'm voting in the the
whole for every single town that doesn't
vat yes everybody position the same as
reps when you have five reps in the town
you get five VES no it it's I there are
five reps one in each of well in my case
eight towns and I get to vote for the
Reps in my town and also every single
other Town that's what happens right now
and I don't see how we are keeping that
also um there is a grandfather provision
on line 8 but my Co-op was formed after
that
time further
discussion yes um I I I I hate to extend
the you know suggest extending this um
executive session I know there we're
going to have more bills to do but but
perhaps um a new version of this
amendment that restores Roman four to
the way it is adds a
Roman well they already got a five why
don't we call it a Roman 8 that that has
this language um in
it and then it's then it's really clear
that that um that that co-ops can choose
the option that they want and this would
then become new option as opposed to
something that would necessarily be
applied retroactively which you know
some districts may have selected Roman 4
as it exists now and not wanted to
select Roman 4 as it's being you know
suggested to be amended so uh because it
does change
it so maybe an maybe an amendment um as
representative fellows was
suggesting
discussion me yes this is your meeting
and I'd like to go back and sit in my
chair but I just want to say if you
decide that you want to have both
options I defer to your judgment but as
a matter of statutory or you know
sponsor intent the intention was to
preclude for the way it's written and
say if this is what you're going to do
have seats assigned to a town then you
need to let that town decide that's my
intent if you take it you know then I
suspect what will happen happen is my
district will stay the way it is forever
and my effort to try and um reform it
will have probably failed as a practical
matter but I I appreciate the you know
the depth of discussion what we had put
in the amendment several years ago
preliminary transitional plan to move
that was required so the end result was
exactly what SP St has right here but we
had a transitional plan in the process
to allow to get to that place and for
the co-ops to make that decision um and
that's where we were back then and
probably we going down a similar path
Poss further discussion on
the on the
yes yeah his point was the point I was
thinking as well is that if we divide
that that out we might as well just
about not do it
because it'll still be the bigger or the
conglomeration of school districts or
the however it works
a a majority of other people will be
determining who is in that because they
won't P they won't vote to change it
they'll be
outnumbered any further
microphone represent luno no I'm good oh
yours you had yours on I had mine off
any other
discussion represented Noble do you have
anything to say nope your is well you're
signaling you
do oh my stuff this modern
technology okay no further discussion on
this so we have have a motion on the
floor mam clerk when you're ready we're
ready the motion is to uh move uh the
OTP Vice chairman cordelli yes Vice
chairman cordelli yes representative
leus yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Leon yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell
yes representative Heath
yes representative luno yes
representative Sullivan yes
representative fellows
no representative Hall yes
representative baloni yes representative
cascaden yes representative Tanner oh
sorry representative Damon yes and
represent chairman lad
yes but 18 Ys two
Nays he now we're on the main motion as
amended 1383 as amended with uh the
amendment we just uh move
yes so thanks I um I I I did support the
amendment I think it was Improvement
upon the um the the bill is introduced
but uh I can't support retroactive laws
and and if if a if a co-op selected
option
for um based on how it was how it
existed in law uh they may not
necessarily want to select option for uh
given the changes and have that um have
that imposed upon them I also don't know
what the um I'm not a lawyer I don't
know what the legal Authority is on on
retroactive um statutory changes so but
thank you further discussion yes
representa
Sullivan I
just shared with the representative
Damon that um I fear that we may have
just lined the pockets of a bunch of
lawyers um
because I I'm not sure exactly how you
get from where districts are now to uh
the next step if their option that they
chose as part of their articles of
agreements is
gone
um if they're they might make
assumptions they might look at um option
five and say that takes care of it um
maybe it does but I'm I'm a bit
concerned represent beler
thank you Mr chair and I won't get into
all the details of the amend of the of
the bill as amended I'll just note based
on on some of the comments I've just
heard that New Hampshire is um is What's
called the Dylan rural State as such
local authorities towns any political
subdivision below the level of the state
has only that Authority specifically
vested to them by the legislature so we
have we totally have the authority to
modify something such as this that would
affect their operating um plans under
that constitutional uh
provision further discussion from the
committee
members not seeing any U Madam clerk
would you please call the rooll the
motion is uh otpa on
1383 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Leon yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative Heath no Representative
luno no representative Sullivan no
representative fellows no no
representative Hall no Representative
bbon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no
chairman lad yes 10 to
10 okay then the motion fails uh
represent
Miler and second we have a motion for
interim study from made by represent
Miler second by represent luno repres
Miler would you like to speak to your
motion yeah I I think uh this has been a
good conversation but I think there are
some questions about the impact of this
uh
proposal on those that already have
uh using option four and I think it'd be
a good time to have a chance to get clar
clarity exactly what happens when you
change a state law as it relates to its
impact upon articles of the Articles of
uh incorporation of uh uh Co-op so
that's why I'm suppose recommending an
interim
study further discussion from the second
sure thank you Mr chair yeah and I I
just you know we we have I appreciate
represent spillsbury being with us for
much of this day um today and and and
his work on this and and honestly I'm
not I I'm I I I don't particularly have
a position on the content it's it itself
but I've got concerns over the
retroactive nature that that that may or
may not be in play here and the fact
that there's no members of any Co-op nor
representatives from co-ops nor
attorneys from co-ops
here to see that maybe the first step of
of of a significant change to their
articles of agreement being um being
proposed so that's why I'm thinking
interim study
too further discussion from the
committee not see any Madam clerk would
you please call the RO the motion is
inim study for 1383 Vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative Belcher no representative
d no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no representative
Leon no representative Terry no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Heath yes
representative luno yes representative
Sullivan yes representative fellows yes
representative Hall yes representative
balbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes
and chairman lad
no 10 y 10 days all right who is writing
the minority or
the interal study interal study and
reever C Deli you're writing the otpa
yep good
enough next one up on the docket here is
1481 relative to apportionments to fill
vacancies at large at Large cour
operative School Board
seat I got read this in front
me okay so a s to apportionments to fill
seats didn't have anybody make these
we I don't just jled my sheet on here
and I don't have it
again
okay do you want to open this up to
enough
okay
[Music]
minutes we got line up people making
motions
bills we don't have a problem in this
build
but is pretty much has is I think it is
too but it just we didn't have anybody
making motions and I wanted to be pretty
that go down through want so what we
yeah
e
sorry
it
OTP yes I would I i' just like to say
that I I think just thinking as a small
town if we lost a member not through
circumstances that we had no control
over I would like it to be replaced by
somebody in our town because that's the
any further discussion on
1481 sure um yes yeah yeah thanks again
there's no representatives from any of
the co-op um districts um here and and
uh and I think this this does change how
things um would be handled in the event
of a vacancy so um I think I would
suggest that alternative
motion okay we have a motion on the
floor any further discussion we have a
motion on the floor the motion is OTP on
1481 made by represent dry and second by
representa cordelli Madam clerk would
you please call the
rule I chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative leam yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative Heath no Representative
luno no representative Sullivan no
representative fellows no representative
Hall no Representative bbon no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no and chairman lad
yes 10 y 10 Nays motion represent Miler
move
the is there a second second we have a
motion on in front of us uh in room
study made by represent Miler second by
represent luno represent Miler would you
like to speak to your motion no we can
move back to thank you very much is that
motion Miler and second by
Luna which
1481 okay 1481 is the bill we discussing
right now we're acting on the motion on
the floor is inter room
1481 Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative
leus no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no representative
Leon no representative Terry no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Heath yes
representative Luna yes representative
Sullivan yes representative fellows yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10
days who's going to write the report
down there write thank you and repesent
dry you've got the other
side okay uh moving on down uh HB 1493
this is relative to the powers and
duties of Cooperative School District
budget
committees look to representative
perinel for a motion yes I move interim
1493 okay we have a motion on the table
on 1493 made by representative pill
second by represent luno the motion is
interim study represent pno yes this is
a topic of um that needs further
discussion and I would like to move
interim study so that we can um continue
the
conversation repr lunal thank
you thank you and where we have a bill
that's dealing with a Cooperative school
districts the interim study you know I
hope that the group that's going to be
doing that we'll go a little bit further
and start looking at some of those
issues dealing with if you want to get
out you know what are the costs of that
building Does it include the
depreciation is it a market value or is
it going to be that $6 million if some
realtor comes up when the actual value
is only $600,000 we got to be looking at
all these this part of the equation and
a lot more so we need inter room study
on a on a bill such as this so any
further
discussion thank you very much um the
motion in front of us is in study in
1493 Madam clerk Vice chairman cour Deli
yes representative leus yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative leyon yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Heath yes representative
luno yes representative Sullivan yes
representative fellows yes
representative Hall yes representative
balbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative
No 19 excuse me excuse me I take n yay
yay yay I'm
surpris you're allowed to do that if you
want 20 Y no Nays okay good with consent
yes thank you very
much um looking at the next one which we
had was
1642 this is this is relative we jumped
over the merging we're coming back to
those bills uh relative to the role of
the Cooperative School District Board
member Representatives on the School
District budget committees
representative
pill thank you I move um ought to pass
on House Bill 1642 is there a second me
represent leus makes that second
representative pel do you want to speak
to your motion yes thank you this um
this bill simply
um let's see that takes the um member of
the school board who's appointed to the
budget committee and puts them in ex
officio non voting capacity so that
therefore the members only have one vote
on each public
second I think she said it very well
thank you any further discussion from
the committee
members looking around the table I don't
see any hand sliming uh so we have a
motion on the table it's referencing uh
14 or
1642 and the motion is
OTP Madam clerk are when you're ready
Vice chairman cardelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Leon yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative Heath no Representative
luno no representative Sullivan no
representative fellows no representative
Hall no representative bon no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no and chairman lad
yes 10 y 10 n motion representative
Miler
move second we have a motion for interim
study made by represent Miler second by
represent luno represent Mayo do you
have any further discussion I do not
represent luno sure again seeing no
representatives from from any Co-op
districts or they're um either either
members of the districts or or um
members of the board or other
Representatives that I think this would
be better left up to um uh to an interim
study so that it could be um discussed
and uh debated in um and and worked on
in in full transparency thank you
further discussion represent
leus given that there's no Amendment and
we had a public hearing where they could
have spoken if they had disagreed I
would think they would have shown up and
the fact that they didn't show up we
don't wait for votes for any of the our
other things or inm study just because
the people it affects don't show up I
decision
we had a lot of bills in this committee
if the public knows what we're doing one
day from another that's good but we did
have the hearing process that is correct
so is there any further committee
discussion if not Madam clerk would you
please call roll the motion is OTP on
164 stud inter excuse yeah interim study
on
1642 Vice chairman cordelli no
representative leus no representative
Belcher no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no representative Leon no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Heath yes representative
luno yes representative Sullivan yes
representative fellows yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Dana Damon and chairman
lad yes no pardon me no do it again no
yeah no
yeah you said three yeses and two NOS
which one I I'm still fixing that
muffler
okay okay so you're going to be doing
that representa luno thank you okay and
representative P you're doing the
opposite thank you we're going back to
everybody should have had an amendment
on on top there it's a very short
Amendment it was passed
ago I have I have more okay does anybody
one did you get one represent c k we
why don't you send those down that way
there
okay
1195 uh representative uh cordelli would
you like to make a motion on 1195 it
would be a pleasure uh I would like to
move on to
pass I'll second
it so we have a motion in front of us
it's OTP on 1195 made by represent
cordelli second by represent lad
represent cordelli would you like to
speak to your motion please uh thank you
I would uh like to uh offer uh Amendment
1125 h and move on to pass on it is
there a
second a second okay represent Dr
seconds the um motion of uh ought to
pass on the amendment 1125
H represent cordelli would like to speak
to your motion thank you um I believe
that this um reflects what we discussed
uh this morning um breaking it up into
two sentences for clarity purposes that
um it aables additional methods of
apportionment uh but any new
apportionment method requires that all
the constituent school districts um
approve that method pursu it to 194
C2 represent dry would you like to speak
I agree I've parsed it and I think it
passes the test thank you thank you very
further discussion from the
committee okay we have a motion in front
of us it's OTP on 1125 H it's amendment
to
1195 when you're ready Madam clerk Vice
chairman cordelli yes representative
leus yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Leon yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Heath yes
representative luno yes representative
Sullivan yes representative fellows yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes representative
lad yes 20 y zero
Nays wow uh
consent consent okay uh represent
cordelli do you like to make a motion
please yes so to pass as amended with
112h second we have a motion made by
represent cordelli otpa on 1195 second
by representative Miler further
discussion from either of the makers
none great any further discussion from
the
you
otpa correct yes okay you're asking me I
don't yes
no I believe it is otpa yeah than Vice
chairman cordelli yes representative
leus yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Leon yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Heath yes
representative luno yes representative
Sullivan yes representative fellows yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
lad yes 20 y zero
n okay that one is obviously going on
consent great thank
you we have one more Bill to do today
and we don't have the copies yet but
representative Pell you say it's
upstairs
okay okay so we'll wait a few minutes
here and see what we got coming at us if
we can get it because there are some
today
1579 on this one right here we've gone
by already this is Wednesday noon so you
know you can you can have a day or two
in it Mark because I know you're going
jeus I lost all my paperwork up here
again it just gets buried yeah I'm an
abstract random if you ever figure that
out not concrete
sequential yeah what look at
this well that's neat in my
yeah
every
e
not collected their Senate bills yet
there's a stack of crisscross on the
desk in there you might pick them up we
received two additional new bills today
that are also Senate bills that are
coming at us so those are on the desk as
well do you know how many we're getting
no I know I don't have a hot clue
more no I haven't seen that I'm waiting
that yeah should that be an
end oh you looking at the new one C5 R
to wait a minute wait minute it's wrong
yeah
C5 Roman to where did I put that well no
no looking at looking at the amendment
of
1579 yeah
there I don't think
so C5 Roman 2 talks about everybody
superintendent shall have only one
superintendent and personnel respons
responsible for superintendent duties
person or no but but the or so you can
either have one superintendent or
everybody except a
superintendent 194
c52 talks about everybody other than the
superintendent performing superintendent
duties so you can either have a
superintendent do everything or you can
have well any any uh Personnel that you
want to employ no but no but right that
says or not and right that's right as in
your so you can either do this or that
so you either have superintendent or you
have everybody except a superintendent
or people do
right well like our school district has
a superintendent and a school business
office yeah you still can do that yep
okay well I'm just so how does the or
make that work because you don't need a
superintendent you could have person
do superintendent
Services yes but we want only one
superintendent super and you don't need
as in current statute you don't need a
superintendent as long as someone's ass
no I I understand that but what if you
have a superintendent and a school
business office that's
or I gotta find out where mine even went
did you have any extra when the
CER yeah right
here
[Music]
delegate okay I'm willing to go I'm
go yeah the superintendent is still
responsible they can delegate all they
want right right take so so C c52
applies both to the first part the one
superintendent e52 applies
there right by definition superintend
minority c52
c52 right which is the other responsible
back I don't know
later
yeah yeah let's get to go
dominoes I know I I
here we have before us the
bill 1579 this is relative to the
and representative pno would you like to
make a motion on this yes thank you I'd
like to move a to pass on House Bill
1579 and there's a second from
representative Miler uh represent uh pno
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you I would like to put forth
Amendment 1128 H and move on to pass on
the amendment is there represent my also
seconds that motion so we have in front
of us now Amendment 11
28h uh to 1579 made by representative
pel and second by represent Miler
represent pel would you like to speak to
your motion please yes thank you we
spoke extensively about this bill this
morning and the changes um that we
discussed have been made in the
amendment we
um tightened up the definition of the
Personnel responsible for superintendent
duties pursuant to RSA 19 4 C5
2A and um eliminated lines 21 to 23 on
the
amendment um eliminated the number um of
students that would be required for
merging districts to achieve once they
merged and um change the word
consolidation um Grant to merged merger
Grant
represent mil would' like
to okay she covered it well
okay further discussion from the
committee we're on the
amendment 1128 H any further
discussion not see any Madam clerk with
the motion is otpa on the
amendment Amendment only representative
dry are you ready Vice chairman cordelli
yes representative leus yes
representative Bel yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Leon yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Heath yes representative
luno yes representative Sullivan yes
representative fellows yes
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes represent
chairman lad yes 28 a no
Nays thank you represent Pell would you
like to make another motion yes thank
you I would move ought to pass as
amended with amendment number 11 11128 h
on thank you very much uh would you like
to speak to your
motion I think we've had enough
discussion I think so thank you
representative Miler same thing when
you're ready Madam clerk motion is otpa
on on the
bill being
1579 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Leon yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Heath yes representative
luno yes representative Sullivan yes
representative fellows yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
lad yes 20 y zero
Nays yes we'll put on consent thank you
very much everybody Mr chair could I
just ask a question um because and I
think it's wonderful this the $200
incentive got into this um because of
that it can't go to fiscal of Finance
because it's already passed so it goes
right to the Senate I think so I would
think so if it passes on the floor yeah
yeah and congratulations I think we need
that incentive to get School District a
great idea now for everybody here that
leaves 13 bills left to exact by this uh
committee this year and that are house
bills yeah and so we'll pick those up on
Monday and you'll also notice that on
Monday we do have a uh a hearing
starting at 9 o' that's for the non-
1450 so then we have 13 bills following
to exec if we don't get them done they
will carry forward to the next day which
is Tuesday the
19th and we have nothing at this point
in time scheduled for the 20th
unless we can't get things done on 19th
we will get things done we're going to
get them done we will get things
done so um I guess that's it for today I
want to thank everybody for hanging in
there and getting what we got we got it
for